[Music]
like I'm on the outside looking in are
like you know like I see this life and
this moment and so wonderful but it
doesn't quite belong to me make any
sense
yeah that song is one of my favorite now
one of my favorite actresses also here
with the shailene woodley plays a
critical acclaimed role of Jane Chapman
on HBO's hit series big little lies
Woodley takes on a new challenge in the
upcoming movie adrift she stars as a
woman who fights for survival after she
and her fiance unexpectedly sail right
into a hurricane adrift is based on a
true story of Tammy Oldham Ashcroft who
endured hurricane Raymond in the Pacific
Ocean in 1983 she battled 40-foot waves
and survived at sea for 41 days before
being rescued
she Linwood Lee who was also a producer
of the movie is joining us now
good morning thank you so I have to say
I took my six-year-old to see a movie
yesterday solo and the trailer for a
drift came up and I'm thinking how is he
gonna react to this because it's quite
intense yeah he's not a great swimmer he
turns to me and he says if I learn how
to swim can I survive that motivation
it'll get you there I love the the
thinking Bahamas processing but you did
your own stunts the director said that
you are a superhero without a cape talk
about that process
thank you is actually referring to Tammy
the room is su rear without the cape but
yeah I got really lucky I mean we filmed
this movie over 90% of it in the open
ocean which just never happens we were
filming outside of Fiji and it would
take us two hours by speedboat to just
get to our shooting location and it was
remarkable you know being in the open
seas and working with the elements in
that way is so rare because we're so
used to sound stages and green-screen
but every day would just put in
perspective of what this you know this
woman went through in real life it can't
be easy though filming out in the open
water I mean I remember reading about
when they tried to shoot Jaws out in the
open
never nothing worked nothing worked it's
not easy but it's worth it I mean you
know we got lucky I love the water and
am a strong swimmer and Sam Claflin
who's also in the film ins as well and
the whole crew was willing to play ball
and but you learned to sail for this
yeah I had to learn to sail which was
amazing I knew nothing about sailing
beforehand and I don't know that I'd
ever choose to go out on a sailboat
alone
now you can yeah well you met the
real-life Tammy :
she in fact wanted you to play her I
mean what did she tell you about what
she went through and how did you take
from her into this role well we got
lucky so she wrote a book which is what
the film is based on and she's so
wonderful which is what the book is but
are the films based on and and the book
had a lot of detail and she was really
generous and open when we had more
questions to ask but it's such a
sensitive subject that I think we were
all very aware of what might be a
traumatising question and what is an
appropriate question and and she was
very generous with what she gave us and
I'm like you she continues to sail even
to this day she's like still into it
even though she went through this
horrifying ordeal a lot of people say oh
it's a woman versus nature story and I
like to say it's it's a woman working
with nature you know that which caused
her the most pain in a way which is the
ocean is also that which helped save her
life and I think that forgiveness that
she's been able to reconcile her work
within her own mind and bought an heart
is what has allowed her to sail today
and when you choose roles especially
roles that you're now participating in
on screen and off as a producer what
makes you decide to go for a real life
story as opposed to fiction oh man I
mean this one this one grabbed me
because of the love story component and
also when it's real it raises the stakes
as an audience member you watch it and I
think in this day and age of big movies
and a lot of fantastic
you know mysticism things that aren't
real it's hard to grasp a relatability
factor and for me when I watch something
that's real it just immediately reminds
me I guess of my own life and how lucky
we are to be alive and puts everything
in perspective and also helps you know
you're not alone in your process when
you're when you're playing a real person
though I mean is does that come with uh
some greater responsibility for sure not
because Tammi put any pressure on me at
all but there's so much self-inflicted
pressure of you know ultimately we hope
audiences love the film and we hope that
critics love the film and you guys love
it but we really wanted to make this for
her we wanted to pay tribute to her
story their story her in Richards story
and so she was the number one critic
that I was the most you know yeah
there's they were they were soul mates
and Richard Sharpe and Tammy and I
wonder for people who will say well I
know how it ends because it's a true
story what would you say to them because
there is a beautiful love story there
yeah they may know the real story but
they may not know how that real story
unfolded and for me what was so powerful
because I'm just such a sucker for love
I love you know it was the love that
aided the survival and without that love
survival may have not existed and so I
think this film does a beautiful job at
explaining how that occurs and and yeah
who doesn't love love and who can't
relate to love right so many people
could relate to change happen right and
big little lies your character come back
for season two now so many people are
anticipating this film that is the show
we starting in launching a new season
huge hits but it also hits a different
tone now with people and identifying
with the me to move minutes something
that the show really delves into talk
about what we can expect in season two
absolutely insane she's so incredible
but yeah you know I think people really
responded to big little lies the first
season I think they'll you know respond
to the second season because we're not
the producers and the writers and
everyone involved in the show isn't
afraid to go there
and to talk about domestic violence and
to talk about things that happen to most
people on this planet and yet very
rarely get told and in mainstream media
in cinemas and in shows so I think I
think people will just continue to feel
like they're not alone in their stories
that's awesome can't wait to see it are
you running for office you've talked
about it who knows Never Say Never I
don't know Never Say Never
Woodleigh thank you very much adrift
opens in theaters
on Friday